Democrats hone in on Trump envoys
Ukraine Kurt Volker President Trump
asked China to investigate the Biden's
and CNN refuses to run Trump ads i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show all
righty well a lot of breaking news today
all of that breaking news starts with a
big hearing that was happening on the
hill yesterday with the Trump Trump
envoy to the Ukraine Kurt Volker who's
the former ambassador former Special
Representative for Ukraine negotiations
and he was communicating with other
officials in the Trump administration
including one guy named Bill Taylor
who's the charge d'affaires at the US
Embassy in Ukraine and Gordon Sunland
the US ambassador to the European Union
Andrei Ermac was an aide to Ukrainian
President Vladimir as olenski and the
president's agent Rudy Giuliani among
others is according to the Democrats
Volcker was one of the people who was
mentioned in the original original
whistleblower story and Volcker was one
of the key players in trying to suss out
what exactly was happening in Ukraine
with regard to corruption well yesterday
Volcker went to the hill to testify and
he testified at length and he also
provided a bevy of texts between himself
and the other mentioned characters just
now people like Giuliani and Bill Taylor
and Gordon Sunland and these texts are
not great for President Trump they're
not good for the Trump administration
now they do leave open one very large
question as we will see and that
question is whether the Trump
administration was indeed conditioning
aid and presidential meetings and warm
relations with the new Ukrainian
administration on getting Joe Biden or
whether they were doing so based on
Ukraine demonstrating that would fight
corruption if the latter there's nothing
wrong if the latter that's exactly what
Joe Biden openly says that he did back
in 2016 Joe Biden there's that famous
audio and video of him talking about how
he withheld 1 billion dollars in
Ukrainian loan aid because he was
attempting to fight corruption in
Ukraine and in 2016 we also know that
the Obama DOJ was meeting with members
of the Ukrainian government and trying
to get them to root out corruption and
we know that in 2018 three Democratic
senators wrote letters to the Ukrainian
government suggesting that their aid
would be conditioned on whether they
cooperated with the Muller probe so in
other words
conditioning aid on fighting corruption
is not in fact a crime conditioning aid
on going after your domestic political
opponent that looks like a quid pro quo
that you're doing for personal benefit
okay so the Democrats have now issued a
letter updating everyone on their
findings and updating everybody on the
content of the texts with Kurt Volker
and here is what the letter says because
we always bring you information first
and then we break it down for you so the
letter is from the head of the House
Committee on Foreign Affairs eliot engel
Adam Schiff who's the chairman of the
house permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence and Elijah Cummings who's
the chairman of the House Committee on
Oversight and reform here's what the
letter has to say quote dear colleagues
we are writing to convey our grave
concerns with the unprecedented actions
of President Donald Trump and his
administration with respect to the House
of Representatives impeachment inquiry
the president and his aides are engaging
in a campaign of misinformation and
misdirection in an attempt to normalize
the act of soliciting foreign powers to
interfere in our elections well as we
will see the question here is whether
Trump and company were soliciting a
foreign power to interfere in the
American election or whether they were
soliciting a foreign power to fight
corruption internally and that has an
impact on American elections because it
turns out that American officials are
involved in Ukraine that's exactly what
the Obama administration was claiming in
2016 that they were trying to root out
corruption in Ukraine and that would
involve investigating people like Paul
Manafort who would go on to be the
campaign chairman for president Trump
according to these three Congress people
we've all now seen the summary of the
call in which President Trump repeatedly
urged the Ukrainian president to launch
an investigation into former Vice
President Joe Biden
immediately after the Ukrainian
president mentioned critical US military
assistance to counter Russian aggression
the president claims he did nothing
wrong even more astonishing he is now
openly and publicly asking another
foreign power China to launch its own
sham investigation against the Biden's
to further his own political aim well a
second we're gonna get to President
Trump and his supposed request to China
he did in fact say that the Chinese
should open an investigation into Biden
but there's no quid pro quo there that's
just from mouthing off because one
difficult things about President Trump
is that he says so many things I've been
saying for years on end and on his
effort epitaphs will be written
President Trump
44th President of the United States he
said
a lot of crap and the problem is that
some of that crap borders on the vulgar
and the obscene to say the least and is
politically unwise to be very mild about
it this China comment falls along those
lines it does not following the criminal
lines but we'll get to that in just a
minute
more of this Democratic letter and these
texts that the media are saying are
incredibly damning and they do raise
questions they do raise questions I'm
not going to pretend that the be texts
are completely by the book and innocent
and non troubling in any way I'm gonna
give you the honest take on all of that
in just at one moment first let's talk
about the fact that Halloween is coming
up we've now entered the month of
October man this year moved incredibly
fast if you've got a family you might be
dealing with something a little scarier
right now than Halloween and that would
be death I mean the possibility of death
that doesn't mean that you're gonna die
right now cause I'm you're gonna die
five years from now it doesn't mean you
should be thinking about life insurance
because let's face it everybody who is
an adult needs to go get life insurance
if the idea of looking for life
insurance intimidates you however you
should try out policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for life insurance online in just
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape and policy genius doesn't just make
life insurance easy they can also help
you find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance again
policy genius makes getting life
insurance incredibly easy to do it's
just a few clicks won't take you that
much time then you never have to think
about life insurance again you can get
back to that buying candy for small
children routine this October takes the
scariness out of buying life insurance
with policy genius go to policy genius
com get quotes apply in minutes you can
do the whole thing on your phone right
now in fact you should pause it you'll
get life insurance come right back
policy genius it's the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance again
that's policy genius calm okay so the
Democrats continue this open letter
that's basically what it is an open
letter in which they inform the media
and they're supposed then they're
supposed to congressional colleagues but
it's about the media attention about
their investigation and their interview
yesterday with Kurt Volker
now remember Volker really only came to
light because Rudy Giuliani the world's
worst lawyer it's amazing he took that
title from Michael Cohen when Michael
Cohen went to jail
President Trump does have an an airing
instinct in choosing the world's worst
lawyer he went to Michael Cohen and he's
like
I'll be great and then he's like you
know who can I replace the world's worst
lawyer with ah I know Rudy Giuliani
that's gone great and really decide you
know be a smart idea I will hold up my
phone on camera and say that I have text
from the State Department no way this
will go wrong in any clique this is why
folks I sort of think that everything is
more easily attributable to comedy of
errors stupidity than it is too deep
malign planning and now both could be
true could be a stupidly carried out
scheme but my general take on the Trump
administration is that when things
appear to have been plans at nefariously
instead they are usually just a
reflection of incompetence and stupidity
because I mean Reid Giuliani have you
seen the man on TV it's not great in any
case the House Foreign Affairs Committee
and the other Democrats they put forward
this letter they say the president
claims he did nothing wrong even more
astonishing he's now openly and publicly
calling for another foreign power China
to launch its own sham investigation
against the Biden's to further his own
political aims this is not normal or
acceptable it is unethical unpatriotic
and wrong American presidents should
never press foreign powers to target
their domestic political rivals I mean I
generally agree with that obviously I
don't think that you should be pressing
the chai calms the Chinese communist
fascist government in Beijing to be
targeting domestic political rivals in
the United States engaging in these
stunning abuses in broad daylight does
not absolve president Trump of his
wrongdoings or his grave offenses
against the Constitution again something
can be wrong and also not illegal also
it could be just Trump mouthing off
which is I think what most Americans
take this for over the past week say
these Democrats new reports have
revealed that other Trump administration
officials may also have been involved in
the illicit effort to get Ukrainian help
for the president's campaign for example
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo has now
admitted that he was on the call when
President Trump explicitly pressed the
Ukrainian president to investigate the
Biden's but failed to report this to the
FBI or other law enforcement authorities
well yeah because he didn't think that
was a crime he thought that was Trump
mouthing off because it probably was but
say these Democrats will recall FBI
director Christopher Rea urged
individuals to report efforts to seek or
receive help from a foreign power that
may intervene in a u.s. presidential
election as we'll see it matters whether
we are talking about a broader attempt
to target corruption which is going to
be the term administration's case or
whether that broad attempt to target
corruption was really just cover for
getting a political opponent this
obligation say the Democrats is not
diminished when the instigator of that
foreign intervention is the President of
the United States it is all the more
crucial to the security of our elections
instead when asked by the media about
his knowledge of or participation in the
call Secretariat Pompeo dissembled
what's not true he didn't lie about him
likewise we are investigating reports
that Vice President Mike Pence may have
been made aware of the contents of the
call and his absence from the Ukrainian
president's inauguration may have been
related to efforts to put additional
pressure on Ukraine to deliver on the
president's demands well that raises the
question as to what the president's
demands were if Trump said Mike don't go
to that inauguration for the Ukrainian
president until he pledges to
investigate Joe Biden that would be bad
if he said we are involved in the
anti-corruption effort in Ukraine don't
go that's exactly what Barack Obama said
to Joe Biden about holding back 1
billion dollars in loan it this week
current and former State Department
officials have begun cooperating with
the impeachment inquiry by producing
documents scheduling interviews and
depositions based on the first
production of materials and it became
immediately apparent why secretary
Pompeo tried to block these officials
from providing information now there the
end from the idea is scanty right
because the fact is within a week
Volcker showed up right the other people
who are asked to testify are going to
testify within the next week and a half
but they have now released these text
messages and the Democrats say these
text messages reflect serious concerns
raised by a State Department official
about the detrimental effects of
withholding critical military assistance
from Ukraine and the importance of
setting up a meeting between President
Trump and the Ukrainian president
without further delay he also expressly
directly expressed concerns that this
critical military assistance and the
meeting between the two presidents were
being withheld in order to place
additional pressure on Ukraine to
deliver on the president's demand for
Ukraine to launch politically motivated
investigations earlier today selected
portions of these texts were leaked to
the press out of context in order to
help correct the public record we're now
providing an attachment with more
complete excerpts from the exchanges my
favorite is that is it then they're not
gonna release the whole exchange just
more complete excerpts how about like
the whole exchange why won't anybody
just do the whole exchange and that's
the stuff we got to see
means the Democrats were out there
saying we ought to see the full
transcript of the Trump Ukraine phone
call and by the way if it exists we
should see a full transcript why the
hell not more information is better for
the American public
sunlight fantastic disinfectant but the
texts that were originally released
yesterday we're a small portion and the
Democrats are now saying well we're at
least this slightly larger portion but
not the whole thing
well why not the whole thing seems like
that would be useful the Democrats
acknowledge that the additional excerpts
we are providing are still only a subset
of the full body of the materials which
we hope to make public after a review
for personally identifiable information
okay good good our investigation will
continue in the coming days but we hope
every member of the house will join us
in condemning in the strongest terms the
presidents had now open defiance of our
core values as American citizens to
guard against foreign interference in
our democratic process now as we will
see the Trump administration case here
is that they are trying to investigate
foreign interference in our election
process and when President Trump is
seeking to investigate what went on in
Ukraine in 2016 that's because he
actually is trying to stop foreign
interference in our election process and
we need help from the current Ukrainian
government in order to investigate that
and come up with the information and
that is not a terrible argument
considering again that earlier this year
three Democratic senators sent a letter
to the Ukrainian government in last year
rather they sent a letter to the
Ukrainian government specifically saying
cooperate with the Muller problem we're
gonna withhold aid so we're gonna have
to determine what exactly was the Trump
administration threatening over so
before the question was were they
threatening and I'd suggested well maybe
they weren't threatening at all maybe
Trump wasn't really threatening anything
on the phone call since the Ukrainians
apparently according to BuzzFeed and the
New York Times did not actually know
military aid was being withheld at the
time of the phone call now it appears
that it was pretty clear to the
Ukrainians that at least a presidential
visit was being withheld or that perhaps
there was some sort of warm relationship
that was in the offing if they would do
an investigation so the question becomes
an investigation into what was this
really about Joe Biden and the cover for
that was corruption talk or was this
really just corruption talk and part of
the corruption talk was talking about
Purisima which is in fact a massive
Ukrainian company run by oil oligarchs
okay so now I get to the actual text and
that have been released by the Democrats
and as I say these are incomplete we
know what the entirety of the text says
so all we can do is go with the excerpts
that we have in front of us on July 19th
so remember the timeline here President
Trump decided he was gonna suspend
military aid to Ukraine back in May
basically and then he informed his own
his own Office of Management and Budget
Director Mick Mulvaney to withhold that
aid starting in mid July July 25th is
the phone call with the Ukrainian
president the whistleblower files the
complaint mid-august Adam Schiff starts
tweeting out the basic claims from the
whistleblower late August early
September the whistleblower complaints
existence is made aware to Congress and
right after that Trump restores the aid
so that is the timeline of events here
okay so a week before the phone call
after the military aid has been
suspended by the Ukrainians don't know
it a week before the phone call with
Trump and zalenski there was a text
between ambassador Volcker who remember
is again the special envoy to Ukraine
there's this text between Volcker and
president Trump's agent and they they
call them presidents from agent as his
lawyer Rudy Giuliani to thank him for
breakfast and introduce him to Andre
Yermak who's a top advisor to president
zalenski volkert texted mr. mayor really
enjoyed breakfast this morning as I
discussed connecting you here with Andre
Ermac who is very close to president
zalenski I suggest we schedule a call
together on Monday maybe 10 a.m. or 11
a.m. Washington time
okay well getting Giuliani on the phone
with Yair Mack doesn't necessarily mean
that it's about Biden it could also be
about broader 2016 interference
questions because Giuliani was in fact
in Ukraine investigating all of that
stuff now Giuliani may also have been
there investigating a bunch of bad
theories right that is that is
significantly plausible the fact is the
president tends to believe conspiracy
theories even if those conspiracy
theories end up not really being true so
maybe he was there investigating a bunch
of nonsense but that does not obscure
the generalized Anti Corruption
possibility which is that he was there
investigating corruption issues as well
okay so it's a little bit vague is it
vague enough to let Trump off the hook
not really but we're gonna find out how
fake it is when we get all the rest of
the text and when everybody
testifies okay so the there's that text
right then wherewhere Volkers putting
together your Mac and Giuliani now
Volker also testified yesterday in front
of the Democrats that he was telling
Giuliani at the time that there was
nothing to the Biden allegations the
Biden allegations were being completely
overblown and that there really was not
a lot of there there which suggests that
he was helping out Giuliani because he
wanted to help out from but that he was
not participating in any sort of quid
pro quo with the Ukrainian government in
fact Volcker testified he was telling
the Ukrainian government the opposite do
not get into the business of interfering
and domestic political arrangements in
the United States it's not gonna run
down to your benefit which means that
what may have here is it another Muller
situation where Trump was informing
people to do bad things and his own team
was saying now we're not gonna do that
that may very well be the case as well
yeah again the president has impulses
that are not good very often and the
people around him are constantly
thwarting those impulses okay I'll get
to the rest of these texts in just one
second first we got to talk about
improving your employees again we have
one employee here his name is Ryan dudes
a stud but let's face it sometimes he
hasn't hit the clips when he is supposed
to on this show and you get lost in his
beautiful blue eyes but at the same time
you're like why is the clip not playing
Ryan why is it not playing well if you
wanted to replace somebody like Ryan the
place that you would look is zip
recruiter com zip recruiters accom is
where you can find the best employees
available to you use zip recruiter
because four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the very first day and
it's not just here at daily wire that we
use zip recruiter over a cafe al-tohra
they're co-owned and Dylan Mouse quits
he needed to hire a director of coffee
for his organic coffee company he
couldn't find qualified applicants
instead he used supporter and within the
very first day he was getting quality
candidates with results like that you
should be using sip recruiters comm see
why zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free and our web address
zip recruit comm slash a daily wire at
zip recruit calm slash daily wired see
ail YW y re zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire okay so we know
that Volker was working with Giuliani
and having Giuliani meet with Andre or
Mack who is the aid to zalenski is that
about Biden or is that about the
investigation into
what happened in 2016 because one of
those things is a public interest the
other thing is based on rumor and
hearsay and without a lot of evidence to
support it now the Trump campaign is
gonna make a bolder claim than I'm
willing to make and that is that the
investigation into Biden is fully
legitimate meaning that they still
suspect the Biden was engaged in serious
corruption over there why is that not a
public interest Mike Pence basically
said that yesterday he suggested that
the American people have a right to know
if the vice-president benefited from his
position when you hold the second
highest office in the land it comes with
unique responsibilities not just to be
above impropriety paid to be above the
appearance of impropriety and clearly in
this case there are legitimate questions
that ought to be asked and we're going
to continue to ask them since the the
American people have a right to know
whether or not the vice president in the
United States or his family profited
from his position okay but the question
is whether you withheld aid over that
would it have been a sign of Ukrainian
corruption if they didn't investigate
the the specific Biden angle now it is
true that today the Ukrainians
apparently reopened a bunch of old
investigations and the media are
reporting this as okay well this is the
other half of the quid pro quo coming
through but that's not really the case
according to the Associated Press
Ukraine's prosecutor general said on
Friday that his office is reviewing all
cases that were closed by his
predecessors including several related
to the owner of a gas company where
former VP Joe Biden's son sat on the
board well it seems to me that if
they're reopening all the old
investigations and some of those
investigations include Bereza what's the
big deal I mean there is a lot of
corruption inside Ukraine you know who
used to say that the Obama
administration you know who used to say
that Joe Biden you know he's to say that
Barack Obama so are we gonna pretend
that the corruption did not exist and
that it's illegitimate to investigate
now buries moas clean as the driven snow
is the idea here
ruslan ryaba shop cos commons came amid
an impeachment inquiry against President
Trump according to the AP ryaba shop cut
told reporters in Kiev that prosecutors
are auditing all cases that were closed
or dismissed by former prosecutors
including several related to me Cola as
low czev ski owner of the gas company
Purisima that hired a hunter Biden in
2014 at the same time his dad was
leading the Obama
Jen's diplomatic dealings with Kiev
though the timing raised concerns among
anti-corruption advocates there's no
evidence of wrongdoing by either the
former VP or his son according to the
Associated Press ryaba Shopko says we
are now reviewing all the cases that
were closed or split into several parts
or were investigated before in order to
be able to rule to reverse those cases
where a legal procedural steps were
taken when asked by a reporter if they
are reviewing cases related to Purisima
and silikov ski the prosecutor said
there are 15 cases were Slav Chesky and
businessmen sir head coach anko are
mentioned he didn't specify how many
were related 200 Biden's work at
Murray's m'a at all where abba shop goes
mentioned on that July 25th call between
Trump and ukrainian President Vladimir
zalenski who assured Trump that ryaba
Shopko was his man and that he would
resume investigations into Purisima okay
so back to these texts
hey so on July 19 2019 ambassador Volker
ambassador sunland this would be the the
ambassador to the EU and Bill Taylor who
is the acting ambassador to Ukraine had
the following exchange about the
specific goal of that phone call that
we've now all read the transcript to
Volcker said can we three do a call
tomorrow say noon Washington Sunland
says Gordon someone says looks like
presidential call tomorrow I spoke
directly to zalenski and gave him a full
briefing he's got it sunlen said sure
Volcker said good had breakfast with
Rudy this morning teeing up a call with
your Mac Monday must have helped most
important is for Solinsky to say he will
help investigation and address any
specific personnel issues if there are
any it is unclear which investigation he
is talking about is he talking about the
Biden investigation is he talking about
the Purisima investigation is he talking
about the generalized 2016 election
interference investigation which one is
he talking about that makes a difference
if at the heart of this lies president
Trump's desire to get Joe Biden and not
root out corruption
you got an impeachable offense if it
turns out that at the heart of this was
president from seeking to root out
corruption and as an aspect of that he's
saying you need to investigate buries
m'a then it's not impeachable and July
21st ambassador Taylor flagged president
solinsky's design notice that none of
these texts actually mentioned Biden
right now one of these text mentions
Biden they all mentioned investigations
most of the mentioned corruption not one
mentions Biden on July 21st 2019
ambassador Bill Taylor flag zelinsky's
desire for Ukraine not to be used by the
Trump administration for its own
domestic political purposes according to
Democrats Taylor said Gordon one thing
Kurt and I talked about yesterday was
Sanchez Sasha Donnelly Oakes points that
president Solinsky is sensitive about
Ukraine being taken seriously not merely
as an instrument in Washington of
domestic reelection politics and sunland
said absolutely but we need to get the
conversation started and the
relationship built irrespective of the
pretext I am worried about the
alternative okay so does that text
message suggest that the Trump
administration is withholding aid based
on the breeze most off or does it sound
like what Sunland and others in the
administration are saying is tell
zalenski that he should just try to
butter Trump up basically and that we
will make the relationship warm based on
anti-corruption efforts hey then we've
got Giuliani advocating for the Trump
zolensky call apparently you're mad can
Giuliani agreed to speak on the morning
of July 22nd later that evening Volcker
informed Sunland and Taylor that
Giuliani was now advocating for a phone
call between Trump and president
Solinsky I'll get to the content of that
particular text exchange remember all of
this is ahead of this cult phone call
between Trump and zalenski we'll get to
this particular text exchange for going
through all of the evidence that is
available because you get information
first here on the show I'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you just read it all
out of your house and it's not looking
like you wanted to look well maybe one
of the reasons is because you got the
ugliest window coverings this side of
the wire and you need better window
coverings good blinds are to a home what
a sharp tie is to a suit it brings it
all together but going blind shopping
isn't something that I particularly
enjoy blinds calm makes it really fast
and really easy which is why I like them
with 15 million windows covered over
30,000 5 star customer reviews
blinds.com is America's number one
online retailer for affordable quality
custom window coverings blinds.com makes
the whole experience incredibly fast and
easy plus every order gets free samples
free shipping a free online design
consultation blinds are a simple
effective way to make your home look
better so what exactly are you waiting
for plus blinds.com is awesome they will
send you free samples to make sure
everything looks as good in person as it
does online every order it's free
shipping and if you screw up the
measurements they will redo it for you
even if it's your fault they've made it
really easy for you
no excuse to have those old ugly window
coverings for a limited time my
listeners get 20 bucks off at blinds.com
when you use promo code Ben that's
blinds.com promo code Benton for 20
bucks off for wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more blinds.com
promo code Ben rules and restrictions do
apply okay so we are continuing to go
through these text messages here is a
text message exchange between Volker and
someone talking about Trump and zalenski
this is on July 22nd just three days
before the Trump zalenski phone call
Volker says orchestrated a great phone
call with Rudy and EUR Mac they're gonna
get together when Rudy goes to Madrid in
a couple of weeks in the meantime Rudy
is now advocating for phone call I've
called in to Fiona's replacement and
we'll call Bolton if needed but I can
tell Bolton and you can tell Nick that
Rudy agrees on a call if that helps and
someone says I talked to Tim Morrison
Fiona's replacement he is pushing but
feel free as well in other words it
looks as though they are trying to get
Rudy Guiliani
to sign off on from talking to so Lenski
on the basis of Rudy is now convinced
that the Ukrainian government is going
to look into the 2016 election stuff or
according to Democrats Rudy's now
convinced that Ukraine will act as a
cat's paw in going after Joe Biden that
part is yet unclear which is why all of
this is gonna come down to in the end
Rudy Giuliani getting up and testifying
in front of Congress that's what this is
all gonna come down to if Rudy gets up
and he says yes I was there yes my only
mission was to go after Joe Biden yes I
tried to force the Ukrainians to go
after Joe Biden not as an aspect of
corruption but just because Joe Biden is
bad man I don't want him elected and
then this looks very much like an
impeachable offense if however Rudy just
says listen I was there to investigate
the 2016 election stuff one of the
aspects of that was Joe Biden and
burries ma and corruption over there and
they made some sort of moves in that
direction so okay then that clouds the
water now is that a good look is any of
this a good look no it's all a terrible
look it's all a terrible look this is
not something that the President of the
United States should have involved his
administration in it is one thing to
deploy your resources to a foreign
country to go investigate it is another
to then try and apply pressure to a
foreign government via military aid to
help your campaign it is unclear so
if that's the let that last thing is
what happened here but why would you
even want the appearance of impropriety
why when President Trump spends his life
walking that edge and eventually you
walk that edge and somebody's gonna push
you off and right now the Democrats are
trying to push him off that ledge now
does that look like a political hit of
course it does because the Democrats are
politically motivated and as it turns
out Paul Sperry the reporter he is
reporting now that the whistleblower in
this particular case was not only a
registered Democrat he was a CIA analyst
who his detail before the 2016 election
to the Obama White House where he worked
on the NSCs at Ukraine desk and met with
the anti-trump Ukrainian officials
before being sent packing by the Trump
National Security Council and becoming
disgruntled this is Paul Sperry
reporting so he says the Democrat
whistleblower who complained about Trump
digging up dirt in Ukraine was himself
helping dig up dirt in Ukraine against
Trump and mana fort while working in the
Obama White House during the 2016
campaign so I'm sure more will come out
about that so does it look like a
political to things can be true once one
can be politically motivated too maybe
there was there there we're about to
find out but we are gonna have to decide
what exactly is impeachable precedent is
the impeachable precedent here that Joe
Biden's name got mentioned is the
impeachable precedent that any attempt
to link funding and corruption is wrong
because if so then Joe Biden it openly
admitted to that or is it that if
there's any confusion at all between the
two then that's impeachable as well
right we again I'm trying to set it up
exactly what we think the standard
should be because everything is moving
goalposts at this point okay so the rest
of these texts on the morning of July
25th 20 19 ahead of the plan call
between Trump and zalenski the
ambassador Volcker advised Andre or
Mexican chinks heard from White House
assuming president Z szalinski convinces
Trump he will investigate get to the
bottom of what happened in 2016 we will
nail down date before visit to
Washington good luck see you tomorrow
Curt ok so this is the text that the
Democrats are focusing in on because
this one obviously has a quid pro quo
right in it right that if the lens he
convinces Trump he's serious they'll
nail down a date for a visit to
Washington good luck see you tomorrow
and that does lead to the phone call
that that that obviously leads directly
into the transcript of the phone call
between Trump and zalenski in which
zalenski is trying to butter up and Moo
Trump 100% obviously now notice what
that text does not mention Joe Biden
right says assuming that zalenski
convinces Trump that he'll investigate
and get to the bottom of what happened
in 2016 that's a legitimate American
interest Ukrainian interference in the
2016 election hell we had a two-year
investigation about Russian interference
in the 2016 election so there is nothing
wrong with the administration or Rudy
Giuliani or anybody in between
investigating what happened in the 2016
election as I say in fact Democrats were
pressuring the Ukrainian government to
work with the Muller probe with regard
to what happens in the 2016 election
only directed at Russia so directing
that same question at Ukraine is not
illegitimate that text is not a smoking
gun that text actually just adds to the
lack of clarity about what exactly is
the investigation we are talking about
by Volkers own testimony it's not Biden
he said he was downplaying the Biden
stuff to to Giuliani but if you are
Trump what makes you nervous right now
is that Rudy Giuliani will be called to
testify and that man has no filter
whatsoever and just says stuff well get
some more of these texts and all of the
rest of the evidence president Trump in
China CNN canceling Trump as we'll get
to all of that in just a second first
and there's nothing more annoying than
spending time with legal documents I
know I'm a lawyer it's supremely
irritating why would you spend any more
time than is necessary dealing with your
legal your your legal fees and your
legal documents it's an it's irritating
it's annoying it's expensive right now
Legal Zoom is making it easier to say so
long to summer by saving you 10% off the
things you need to accomplish for all
you entrepreneurs they haven't set up an
LLC or DBA or an S corp for your
business now is the time to save some
money you've been meaning to wrap up
your last will living trusts but you
can't seem to find the time
take a moment do the right thing for
your family and if you get confused or
have questions don't let that slow you
down either Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
I've been using them for years however
their network of independent attorneys
and law and tax professionals can give
you the advice you need to make the
right decisions I've been using Legal
Zoom myself for years long before they
were an advertiser on the program going
all the way back to law school if I
needed to do any sort of simple document
for my own personal legal business
I would head on over to LegalZoom save
10% for a limited time on the things
you've been meaning to do with LegalZoom
just go to legalzoom.com right now
use code bend at a checkout that's
LegalZoom where life meets legal
legalzoom.com
right now use code been at checkout for
special discounts Legal Zoom calm and
use code been at checkout ok back to
these texts in just one second first you
have to go subscribe over at daily
wire.com $9.99 a month men's and bucks a
year you know the drill also great news
another Kingdom fans the third final
season is here this Monday October 7th
episodes 1 & 2 will be released but if
you're a subscriber you get exclusive
access to both today October 4th so do
not wait go subscribe right now if
you're in the game of Thrones and our
hard-boiled fiction about detective
fiction another Kingdom is for you also
subscribers exclusively can catch up on
past seasons right now over at daily
wire.com go check it out it's a really
cool project that we've undertaken with
Andrew Clavin and the execrable Michael
know let's go check us out at daily
wire.com also it is that glorious time
of the week when I give a shout-out to a
daily wire subscriber you right here you
ready are you right here we go today
it's Twitter or Jordan s who understands
the importance of proper pet nourishment
it's pretty much a guarantee by the way
they've put your pet by the tumblr you
have a solid shot at getting into the
the tumblr into the tumblr promo in the
pic Jordans and leap beverage vessel has
been commandeered by her pet snake soba
oh my god who's sticking its head out
just above the rim smiling for the
camera just like a true leftist would
the caption reads soba soaks in the
leftist here's tumblr the salty tears to
stain her and soften her old skin she's
days away from shedding and in full
zombie mode she refuses to leave the
tumblr and I fear for my hands life I
dare try to remove her it's true our
tumblers provide essential health
benefits for all walks of life including
temperamental zombie snakes thanks for
the picture
good luck getting your tumblr back also
you have a snake for a patent which you
know that's that's a call that's a call
I will say alrighty so go subscribe
right now 99 bucks a year got to see the
subscription you get the very greatest
in all the beverage vessels and please
subscribe it really does help us bring
you the show every single day we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so back to these texts so uh
so your Mac apparently gave sort of an
informal readout of the Trump Solinsky
call after the call
ambassador Volker received a readout
from the Ukrainian presidential advisory
Ermac and confirmed his intent to meet
Giuliani Madrid and Rex had phone call
went well president Trump proposed to
choose any convenient dates president
Solinsky chose 20 21 22 September for
the White House visit thanks again for
your help
please remind mr. mayor to share the
Madrid date Volcker said great thanks
and we'll do hey then on August 9th 2019
this is the other text message that
people aren't honing in on so they're
really - in this whole exchange people
are honing in on one is the the obvious
quid pro quo but for what and that is
the Volcker message saying that if
zalenski convinces Trump he'll
investigate and get to the bottom of
what happened in 2016 we can nail down a
date for a visit in Washington right
it's not clear what the investigation is
that he's mentioning which is the entire
thing okay that is one text message
people are honing in on the other one is
this exchange is about ambassador
Volcker and sunland about arranging a
White House meeting after the Ukrainian
president makes a public statement quote
someone says Morris and ready to get
dates as soon as you're met confirms
Volcker says excellent how did you sway
him sunlen says not sure I did I think
president really wants the deliverable
Volcker said but does he know that
someone said yep clearly lots of convos
going on Volkers are okay and it's good
it's coming from two separate sources
someone says to avoid misunderstandings
might be helpful to ask Andre for a
draft embargoed so that we can see
exactly what they propose to cover even
though zalenski does a live presser they
can still summarize in a brief statement
thoughts and Volker says agree so what
exactly is supposed to be in that
Ukraine statement what exactly is this
brokered agreement basically what what
what is the deliver all but that the
president wants and is mentioned there
by someone well on August 9th 2019 after
Giuliani met with President solinsky's
aid Andre Ermac Volcker asked to speak
with Giuliani about the Ukrainian
statement Volcker said hi mr. mayor
had a good chat with your Mac last night
he was pleased with your phone call
mentioned zalenski making a statement
can we all get on the phone to make sure
I advised Olinsky correctly as to what
he should be saying I want to make sure
we get this done right thanks
someone said good idea Kurt I'm on
Pacific time and Giuliani said yes you
can call now
to fundraiser at 12:30 the next day
president solinsky's a dr mac pressed
ambassador Volcker for a date for the
White House visit before committing to a
statement announcing an investigation
explicitly referencing the 2016 election
in breeze ma so that that is the
Democratic description here is the
actual exchange so your MEC says hi Curt
please let me know when you can talk I
think it's possible to make this
declaration and mention all these things
which we discussed yesterday but it will
be logic to do after we receive a
confirmation of date we inform about
data visit and about our expectations
and guarantees for future visit let's
discuss it Volker says okay it's late
for you why don't we talk in my morning
your afternoon tomorrow say 10:00 a.m.
5:00 p.m.
Volker says I agree with your approach
let's iron out statement and use that to
get date and then president Z can go
forward with it your ex is okay Volkers
is great Gordon is available to join as
well your max is excellent once you have
a date we will call for a press briefing
announcing upcoming visit and outlining
vision for a reboot of US Ukraine
relationship including among other
things Purisima and election meddling in
investigations and Volker says sounds
great okay so here is where you start at
the first time in any of these texts the
explicit mention of breeze mo right and
Purisima is mentioned in the context of
election meddling in investigations and
corruption that is happening in Ukraine
Biden isn't mentioned here but it's
pretty obvious that the the mention of
Purisima is meant to be about Joe Biden
so if you're a Democrat and you're
looking at this you're saying okay this
is starting to look like a smoking gun
right it's starting to look like Trump
asked your Mac and zalenski to mention
that they would investigate buries mine
in return they get to visit the White
House if you are the Republicans if
you're Trump and his administration what
you're saying is President Trump has a
wide variety of things he thinks are
corrupt in Ukraine those things include
Purisima but are not restricted to
buries m'a and the president is trying
to fight corruption and thus he is
asking for some sort of guarantee about
reopening investigations into a wide
variety of topics including buries mo
right so the question is is now the
Biden buries most of its own thing that
Trump is specifically asking for and
focusing in on and the corruption stuff
is just an excuse or is it under the
broader rubric of anti-corruption and
that one is you know it's frankly it's
hard to say it is I mean it's very hard
and this is why I keep coming back to
Rudy Giuliani's gonna have to testify
about this stuff
we need to see the full-text of the
exchanges we need to see Rudy Guiliani
testify more information better
information these are open questions now
only we have conclusive evidence but the
text messages are sure not good for the
Trump administration following the
August 9th 2019 outreach to Giuliani
Volcker and sunland hadn't exchanged
regarding the proposed Ukrainian
statement Volcker said special attention
should be paid to the problem of
interference in the political processes
of the United States especially with the
alleged involvement of sub Ukrainian
politicians I want to declare that this
is unacceptable so here is the Trump
case where's Volkers case I am
explicitly saying I do not want Ukraine
involved in US elections right in these
texts so we are talking about the
broader rubric of corruption because I'm
explicitly ruling out Ukrainian
interference in the American election
process right he says I want to declare
that this is unacceptable
we intend to initiate and complete a
transparent and unbiased investigation
of all available facts and episodes
including those involving Purisima and
the 2016 US elections which in turn will
prevent the recurrence of this problem
in the future and someone says perfect
let's send to Andrey after our call
right so obviously Trump's team is
saying basically the burries might is
part of the broader corruption inquiry
just as manna fort was brought part of
the broader obama corruption inquiry
into ukraine in 2016 on August 17th 2019
Volcker and someone had an exchange in
which they discussed their message to
Ukraine someone says he still wants
olenski to give us an unequivocal draft
at 2016 and Purisima Volcker says that's
the clear message so far I'm hoping we
can put something out there that causes
him to respond with that
sunlen says unless you think otherwise
I'll return Andres call tomorrow suggest
they send us a clean draft on August
28th zalenski xavier mack texted
ambassador Volcker a news story titled
Trump holds up Ukraine military aid
meant to confront Russia Airmech said
need to talk with you Volcker said
absolutely on August 30th Trump canceled
his trip to meet Celine ski bill Taylors
and this is the first year here at Bill
Taylor in these exchanges bill Taylors
and Obama era holdover and so this has
led to some suspicions that bill Taylor
was either working with the
whistleblower or the bill Taylor was
basically trying to create a narrative
that this was all about Biden not merely
about anti-corruption bill Taylor said
trip canceled
volker said hope the vice-president
keeps the bilateral and sees up a White
House visit Sunland says I'm going
Pompeyo is speaking to the president
today to see if he can go Bill Taylor
says are we now saying that security
assistance and White House meeting are
conditioned on investigations and
someone says call me so Democrats are
saying well that's suspicious because
why are they now using phones and not
texting so Sunland is gonna be called to
testify as well okay and now bill Taylor
is starting to to really get upset about
all this right Bill Taylor starts
texting Volker and Sunland and he's
saying guys is this really a quid pro
quo for the Biden right bill Taylor says
the nightmare is they give the interview
and don't get the security assistance
the Russians love it and I quit right in
other words that they are going to start
to do these convert these these
investigations and the Democrats are are
and and then the ADA's held up to
Ukraine anyway and then here is the one
that the Democrats are really focusing
on extreme in extreme fashion today okay
so this is the final one there are three
real exchanges one is that suppose it
quid pro quo over Biden but it may in
fact be over generalized investigations
one of them is the conversation about
the possibility of withholding a date
unless there is some sort of press
statements that mentions the 2016
elections in breeze m'a and here's the
third one
between bill Taylor and Gordon Sunland
Taylor says the message to the
Ukrainians and Russians we send with the
decision on security assistance key what
the hold that we've already shaken their
faith in us thus my nightmare scenario
Taylor says counting on you to be right
about this interview Gordon and someone
says bill I never said I was right I
said we are where we are and believe we
have identified the best pathway forward
let's hope it works
Taylor says as I said on the phone I
think it's crazy to withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign and someone says bill I believe
you're incorrect about president Trump's
intentions the president has been
crystal clear no quid pro quos of any
kind the president is trying to evaluate
whether Ukraine is truly going to adopt
the transparency and reforms president
zalenski promised during his campaign I
suggest we stop the back-and-forth by
text if you still have concerns I
recommend you give Lisa Kenna or s a
call to discuss them directly
thanks I don't know who s is in the
particular conversation okay so bill
tailor obviously thinks it's a quid pro
quo Sumlin is saying it is not a quid
pro quo Volker is saying it is not a
quid pro quo at least with regard to the
the actual investigation invite so that
is where things stand does this make us
more suspicious today than we were
yesterday about the transcript of the
phone call the answer there has to be
yes obviously because there were
obviously negotiations taking place now
were those predicated on Biden
specifically or was it about a broader
corruption effort unclear now and
another piece of news the Democrats are
jumping on today The Wall Street Journal
reported that President Trump ordered
the removal of the Ambassador to Ukraine
after months of complaints from allies
outside the administration including
Rudy Giuliani that she was undermining
him abroad and obstructing efforts to
persuade Kiev to investigate former Vice
President Joe Biden according to people
familiar with the matter so there's that
there's always that anonymous sourcing
the recall of Jovanovic in the spring
has become a key points of interest in
the house impeachment inquiry a
whistleblower complaint by a CIA officer
alleges the president solicited foreign
interference in the twenty20 elections
the complaint cites yovanovich as ouster
as one of a series of events that paved
the way for what the whistleblower
alleges was an abuse of power by the
president State Department officials
were told this spring Alvin ovitch his
removal was a priority for the president
a person familiar with the matter said
Secretary of State Pompeii has supported
the move
Javan know which was told by the State
Department they couldn't shield her from
attacks by the president's and his
allies according to people close to her
in an interview Rudy Giuliani told The
Wall Street Journal in the lead-up to
Yavin overtures removal he reminded the
president of complaints percolating
among Trump supporters that she had
displayed an anti-trump bias in private
conversations in mr. Giuliani's view she
had also been an obstacle to efforts to
push Ukraine to investigate Biden and
his son hunter so again this is why if
Rudy testifies some real problem for
Trump because it sounds like in this
interview the Giuliani is telling The
Wall Street Journal that Trump fired an
ambassador because she was not
attempting to push forward the Biden
investigation in Ukraine which looks
real ugly so you know all of this
doesn't look fantastic for sure however
the Wall Street Journal also reports
that when Jana Ivanovitch left her post
in May the State Department said she was
concluding her
as planned shoes were called three
months before the end of her customary
three year at diplomatic tenure Giuliani
told the Journal that when he mentioned
the Ambassador to the president this
spring from thought that she'd already
been dismissed Giuliani said he
subsequently received a call from a
White House official asking him to list
his concerns about the ambassador again
he then gave Pompeo the Secretary of
State a nine page document dated March
28th that included a detailed timeline
of the Biden's dealings in Ukraine and
allegations of impropriety against
yovanovich including that she was very
close to mr. Biden okay well that's a
different thing right in other words if
Giuliani is saying that Yavin ovitch is
basically a Democrat appointee and that
she is very close to Trump's political
opponents and that that's a problem
Trump does have plenary power over the
executive branch that doesn't mean that
they are firing her for holding up an
investigation into Biden if you believe
that somebody is stacked against any of
your interest because you are a
Republican and that person is a Democrat
this is why for example it's pretty
customary to fire all of the US
attorneys when you enter office as
presidents of the United States so the
the question in this story is again
whether this was about the Biden
investigation in Ukraine and Yavin of
its not participating in it or whether
it was about she was a Democrat from
some Republican and like her okay now
all of this is is exacerbated yesterday
because President Trump then decides to
go out publicly on the South Lawn of the
White House and call on China to
investigate the Biden's which of course
adds to the miasma and fog of complaints
that President Trump keeps going out
there and asking foreign countries to
investigate Biden they were honest about
it that sort of major investigation into
the bike it's a very simple answer they
should investigate the budges because
how does a company that's newly formed
and all these companies if you look at
and by the way likewise China should
start an investigation into the bodies
because what happened to China
is just about as bad as what happened
with with Ukraine okay so people are
jumping on this and they're saying well
that now now Trump is just throwing out
their quid pro quos he's asking for
foreign interference okay no this is
Trump riffing okay this is John Belushi
in Animal House he's just saying stuff
because that's what he does he does now
the Democrats and the media they are
trying to claim that Trump has already
raised Biden in calls with Xi Jinping
but the fact is that he was just again
riffing in a conversation with Xi
Jinping during a phone call with Xi on
June 18th Trump raised Biden's political
prospects as well as those of Elizabeth
Warren okay so that that has nothing to
do that that's not Trump asking for
China to investigate Biden in exchange
for something right that is just Trump
mentioned Biden's name which Trump is
apt to do cuz dude has no filter
apparently in that call I mean what is
more troubling is Trump told you he'd
remain quiet on Hong Kong protests as
the trade talks progressed which is in
and of itself a moral problem but that
is not a moral problem that goes to the
the heart of the of the criminal
activity alleged and by the way why
exactly is is Trump mentioning China
well because hunter Biden formed an
investment consulting firm called
Rosemont Seneca with the with with
relative of John Kerry and then he met
with two top executives of China's
sovereign wealth fund social security
fund and largest banks hey they're not
gonna meet with hunter Biden unless Joe
Biden as his daddy now does that mean
that that Joe Biden is involved in the
corruption they're not really but it
doesn't mean that hunter has been taking
advantage of daddy's name and he's been
doing that for a very long time
Jim Garrity and National Review says
it's fair to wonder just what Rosemont
Seneca had to offer huge institutional
investors beyond the step son of a top
Democratic senator turned Secretary of
State John Kerry and the son of the vice
president it certainly wasn't a big firm
Trump and Giuliani keep insisting the
Chinese paid or gave hunter Biden 1.5
billion dollars that's not quite
accurate hunter Biden davon Archer
Jonathan Lee other business partners
formed pH our partners in June 2013
hunter Biden was an unpaid member of the
board who seats his share of the money
after his father left the White House
but obviously his name being attached
was not unhelpful was not unhelpful on
any
that and so here is where things
currently stand we need more information
we need more Giuliani is gonna end up
testifying Giuliani should end up
testifying he is at the center of all of
this was all of this merely an attempt
to get Joe Biden via Ukraine by
pressuring Ukraine with a quid pro quo
or was this just an extension of the
same efforts that the Obama
administration was making to ferret out
corruption inside Ukraine and fight that
corruption by withholding aid that's
what Joe Biden was doing and what Barack
Obama was doing and again I mentioned
that Hillary Clinton was in fact
involved in election shenanigans with
the Ukrainian government in 2016 and so
that does not justify the president's
behavior Hillary wasn't president at the
time but it does provide a backdrop for
the possibility of impeachable offenses
because if Obama did not commit an
impeachable offense and Trump did the
same thing then presumably that's not an
impeachable offense okay time for a
quick thing that I like and then we will
get to a thing that I hate so thing that
I like you know as I say over the
weekends I tend to read lots of books
one of the books that I read in the
non-jewish realm because it was Rosh
Hashanah I was reading a lot of Jewish
books from one of the books that I read
a sort of a break is a really terrific
tennis book called strokes of genius by
L John wartime about the rivalry between
Rafael Nadal and Roger Federer I have to
admit that I am a Federer fan I'm not as
much of a NATO fan Nadal is a terrific
player if you have to take one of those
players all-time it's probably Federer
but if let's put it this way if Federer
had Nadal's mentality he'd have about 35
majors right now in any case this is
about the 2008 Wimbledon final where
nade all finally broke through at
Wimbledon it's a really good book john l
john war time the book has strokes of
genius well worth the read ok time for a
quick thing that I hate
all righty so there's this clip that is
going around last night in which some
woman gets up and suggests that the only
solution to global warming is to eat
baby she does this at an AOC town hall
meeting and again you know III want to
be fair
believe it or not to AO say this lady
who's speaking her is either crazy or my
in my humble opinion a troll or
prankster she immediately starts saying
to a OC the only solution to global
warming is to physically eat children we
only have a few months left I love that
you support the Green Deal but it's not
get it you know getting rid of fossil
fuel it's not gonna solve the problem
fast enough so I think your next
campaign slogan has to be this we got to
start eating babies we don't have enough
time there's too much co2 all of you
you're here you know your pollutants too
much co2 you know even if you would barb
Russia we still have too many people too
much pollution so we have to get rid of
the babies that's a big problem just
stopping babies a silent lap we need to
eat the babies okay so a OC was getting
all sorts of flack for not shellacking
this woman and saying no we're not gonna
eat babies again I'm fair to aoc here if
this were me it would seem like this
person actually had a problem right and
and that I would you know again I think
IOC respond sir is actually correct
right she says hey everyone we had a
fabulous Town Hall tonight I'll be
highlighting some moments from it at one
point I was concerned there was a woman
in crisis and want to ensure we treat
the situation compassionately let's not
mock or make a spectacle for all let's
work on Medicare for all I know what
Medicare for all has to do with anything
but again when you watch that clip I I
kind of agree with aoc stake on this she
says this person may have been suffering
from a mental condition and it's not
okay that the right wing is mocking her
and potentially making her condition or
crisis worse well I don't think the
right wing is mocking her I think
they're pointing out that the that she's
probably pranking you should be a decent
human being and knock it off
you know as far as the quote unquote
right wings reaction not not really not
really super into it you know I don't
think that AOC is characterizing the
right properly and I also don't think
that Donald trum
is is characterizing her response
properly you know everybody faces down
when they're in public events everybody
faces down people who are kind of crazy
who get up and say things and the best
thing you can do sort of tut-tut it
until it goes away
I honestly I'm not gonna get on a C's
case about that I also I'm not sure why
she is getting on everybody else's case
about it okay other things that I hate
one quick thing Sam B is just the worst
Samantha B is supposed to be a comedian
but she has not been funny for several
years she's kind of like low-rent Hannah
Gadsby so she went and met with the
squad and became an honorary member of
the squad and boy was it so unfunny my
goodness didn't ever to find a place of
calm in this political storm I went to
DC to sit down with congresswoman Omar
aka the president enemy number one and
member of the bomb GOG
[Music]
hmm not produced at all not funny at all
my goodness that is some terrible
terrible stuff from Samantha bee but it
is the the horror to which we have grown
accustomed already we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours
all the updates otherwise we will see
you here next week I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jessica alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation